welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is professor Patrick kors an
assistant professor of history at Yale
professor course teaches courses in u.s.
international history and the history of
European and international politics he
is the author of the unfinished piece
after world war one professor kors is
currently working on a history of the
Pax Americana which re appraises
American pursuits of a new world order
from their origins to the Cold War and
explores how far they contributed to the
emergence of a more legitimate
international system welcome professor
course thank you thanks for having me
sure let's begin with your first book
the unfinished piece after world war one
what is its premise well it's premise
and short is that it in my
interpretation it would be misleading to
regard the ear after World War one as
one marked by the illusion of peace by
the failure of making any kind of peace
what I'm looking at is rather the
construction of something that emerged
in the 1920s as a transatlantic piece
system but I also argue and that is
somewhat different from previous
interpretations that one shouldn't focus
too much on the peace negotiations at
Versailles in 1919 in looking for the
origins of this piece but rather look at
efforts that were made in the 1920s to
reform what was originally and not so
stable international order at Versailles
and that is what I'm looking at and I'm
particularly interested in ria praising
the role that the United States and
Britain played in this process ok and
what drew you to this topic um in a way
I've always been generally interested in
origins of wars and what made for
workable lasting peace systems
especially in the 20th century and and
this book offers in some ways an
explanation of white came to a second
world war and that's of course a big
question and that has sort of had my in
court my interest for for a long time
one particular I think point here is
that I've long been interested in
transatlantic relations and in the role
that the United States played in the
emergence of a really global
international order from the 19th
century onwards to the era of the Cold
War and so in all of this I thought the
year after World War one was an
interesting one to focus on all these
interests that I had okay I imagine that
there is quite a bit of archival
material out there tell us a little bit
about the research you needed to do for
the book yes it's at once I guess quite
challenging but also a lot of fun in a
way because I I think that to be really
valuable nowadays history should be
written in this kind of area as
genuinely international history which
means that one has to go to a lot of
archives in different countries and my
projects are this mainly involves
archival research in the United States
but also in Europe in particular in
Britain and France and in Germany it
requires me to go to Paris on a regular
basis so there are many sacrifices
involved yes tough i'm sure in writing
the book did it did you think that
perhaps there are any lessons to be
learned here for instance regarding like
the Middle East conflicts and other
regions that are in conflict I would say
so yes I mean it is always difficult to
draw lessons from historical periods and
to find very exact analogies but I think
one of the things I'm trying to analyze
in this book is what I regard as the
emergence of a franco-german peace
process with two very distinct states
and sets of interest in German wyman
Germany of the time and France from
having a lot of conflicts over salient
issues and so I'm not least looking at
the question what an outside broker a
third force a kind of arbiter can do and
in this particular case what Britain and
the United States could do to in a way
enable such a piece
to have any kind of success and this of
course requires not least taking over
international commitments and the United
States after the first world war was a
power after the treaty negotiations of
versailles and the rejection of the
treaty of SI by the American Congress
that seemingly did not want to take on
and the international commitments to
security to European reconstruction but
as my book I think shows to a certain
extent this is partly a myth so the the
difficulties involved for power to
actually play a constructive
international brokering role and I think
a central theme of the book and I think
this is something that if we look at the
Middle East nowadays or efforts to for
example reform international financial
order that seemed to be quite on the
agenda a lot of lessons can be drawn
from the successes but also of course
notably the failures of the interwar
period okay and you're working on a new
book a history of the Pax Americana did
the idea of that book grow out of this
first book yes to a certain extent I
would like to say first of all that the
Pax Americana is in quotation marks so
it's it's it's it's a book about an idea
but also the translation of the idea of
a kind of American peace such as Woodrow
Wilson tried to promote in nineteen
eighteen nineteen nineteen but also
successive generations under the
Roosevelt administration the Truman
administration's try to promote and yes
in a way the the period that I'm
especially interested in this marked by
two world wars and two attempts to
re-order into the international system
and the United States played a very
marked role in both attempts so this
book is a really a an attempt to to try
to look at this period in one coherent
analysis which is quite somewhat of an
undertaking but I'm especially
interested in these you know lessons and
learning processes that you mentioned
what was different after 1945 how far
did for example American policymakers
try to draw lessons from the failures of
their side from the failures of
stabilizing for example a democratic
Germany in the 1920s and what did they
try to do differently under the
conditions of the emerging Cold War
so clearly there's a relation between
the first book in the second book all
bored very boring maybe not at all so in
terms of you know the new book that
you're working on I know you're in the
process of writing it can you share any
any any of your findings at this point
any highlights that we can look forward
to reading about um I think it's it's
really an ongoing process but I am I've
become ever more interested in looking
at what i would call the history of
ideas not just the ideas of let's say
you know the big met the big three and
at versailles or the great statesman but
also ideas that were brought forward by
non-governmental groups peace activists
others who try to have an influence of
how the United States redefined its
international role and to compare you
know what some of these groups the leak
to enforce peace or others try to have
in terms of influence on the
international system and compare that
with what for example State Planning
State Department planning amount or two
and I think this is a very quite a
complex history but but also a very kind
of rewarding history it's it tries to
open the view on international history
as not being just maybe Otto stuffy old
boring diplomatic history but a more
comprehensive international history
these are not very precise findings but
i think that's that's sort of what I'm
particularly working on at this point
okay and do you have any kind of a
timeline for the new book when can we
expect it I have I'll be on leave next
year so I hope to make white some
headway on this book then I would be
somewhat surprised if I actually managed
to finish it because it's quite a big
broken in the making but in the it's it
should come out in the foreseeable
future okay wonderful well thank you so
much for being with us here today and
sharing some research thank you I really
appreciate the opportunity okay for more
information about professor cores and
his work please visit our website at
yale edu backslash macmillan report
please be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty McMillan
Center for International and area
studies
you